Today I wanna talk to you
about a book that has real
application for language learning.
You know that I'm going to
Sweden, Denmark, Poland.
In preparation, I've been
listening to audiobooks and
reading eBooks on LingQ, of course.
And I discovered this wonderful
Danish, um, audiobook ebook from the,
uh, online publisher called Saxo.
And the book is, is called
lev mere tænk mindre.
Pardon my Danish pronunciation, but
it means live more and think less.
And, uh, it's by Pia Callesen,
and she talks about what is called
metacognitive therapy, helping
people who have, you know, stress
and feel depressed and so forth.
Now, I'm not suggesting that language
learners are depressed, but one of the
symptoms of this depression that a lot
of people face, Is this sort of fear,
call it the social anxiety disorder.
Uh, one of the many kinds of, of negative
feelings that people can develop.
And she explains why people develop
them and how to deal with it.
So it's explained in the book
that typically we are bombarded
by thoughts all day long.
70,000 thoughts she says, okay.
Many of those thoughts are negative and
people who struggle with depression,
it's not because they have more
negative thoughts than other people,
but it's because they spend too much
time with their negative thoughts.
They ruminate, they cogitate.
So again, it's explained in the book
- and there's also an English language
version of the book and it is based on
this, uh, metacognitive therapy, which
came out of the University of Manchester
in England - and she says, so there are
sort of three levels of our thinking.
At the lowest level are all of these
thoughts that come at us, many of which
might be doubts and negative thoughts
and so forth, and tens of thousands.
We all get them.
At the next level is
how we deal with them.
So some people spend a lot of
time delving into these negative
thoughts, wondering, how did I do?
Uh, does he or she like me?
Am I gonna be fired?
Uh, is my pronunciation in English bad?
You know, some of the
language learning anxieties.
People are gonna judge my
ability and the language.
All these negative thoughts, we can sort
of dwell on them, which only makes us more
unhappy or we can choose to ignore them.
And she points out in the book that
the sort of key to having a strategy of
ignoring these negative thoughts, which
she calls trigger thoughts, which can
trigger sort of anxiety or unhappiness.
The key is to have a belief system.
The belief system will determine
the strategy that we use to
deal with all of these thoughts.
So if we believe that dwelling on these
thoughts, thinking about them, uh, is
gonna help us, then that's what we do.
Uh, if we think that these thoughts
are outside of our control, or at
least the negative impact of these
thoughts are outside of our control.
If we think that there's, it's a
function of, say, a, in the case of
people with, uh, depression, that
is because of a negative imbalance,
then they might go for medication.
Or if they think that a psychologist
can analyze these thoughts and find out
the reasons why we have these negative
thoughts, and in other words, continue
to dwell on them, if we think that's the
right strategy, then that's what we'll do.
And in many cases, we'll be very unhappy.
If on the other hand, the belief system
is that these thoughts are within our
control, we can choose to ignore them.
We can choose to only deal with
them at a certain time of the day.
Uh, we can choose to address
our focus somewhere else and not
focus on these negative thoughts.
And if we feel that that's the
right strategy, if that's our
belief system, then we will adopt
a strategy, a positive strategy for
dealing with these negative thoughts.
So I, I think this has real application
for language learning, because very
often, yeah, we wanna be happy that we're
learning the language, but we want to be
focused on the enjoyment of the language,
of feeling that moment when we're with
the language where it's an outward focus.
It's a focus on the language, on
the audio, the, the language that
we're listening to, or that we're
reading or we're speaking to people.
And so it's outward, not inward,
not how did I do, how am I doing?
You know, is this right?
Is that right?
Why do I make mistakes?
Why do I forget?
So if our sort of mindfulness around our
language learning is one of enjoying what
we're doing in an outward facing way,
then that's gonna be positive for us.
If on the other hand, we somehow
feel that we have to indulge all
these doubts and neg negative
thoughts, that's probably going to...
won't drive us into depression, but
it will hinder our language learning.
And so I just, whenever I read
something on any subject, I always
bring it back to language learning.
And I just feel that that is
a, is a discipline and that
sort of is an understanding.
What are our beliefs in terms of how
we deal with these negative thoughts
that we are going to get negative
thoughts about our language and our use
of the language, we're gonna get them.
How do we deal with them?
That's determined by that
higher level, our belief system.
If we have a belief system that
says the mistakes don't matter,
we don't need to dwell on them.
We don't need to try to
remember, you know, how did I do?
Why did I make a mistake?
None of that matters.
It's going forward, enjoying the
language, appreciating what we have
done and where there are negative
thoughts, which there will be.
Everyone has them.
We just ignore them or
detach ourselves from them.
So I just thought that was a very
interesting, uh, book with real
application for language learning.
Check out the link in English probably,
although if you're trying to learn Danish,
you might wanna check out the Danish book.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.